Will Black Adam and Shazam ever clash on screen?
It has almost happened a couple times, but one
person stood in the way: Dwayne Johnson. Here's
why he put the kibosh on this clash of the titans.
The 2022 release of "Black Adam" was
the culmination of years of production,
beginning with Dwayne Johnson being cast
in the titular role all the way back in
2007. Black Adam's arrival on the big screen
was preceded by the 2019 film "Shazam!" That
film followed the story of a foster child named
Billy Batson who gets infused with superpowers,
including flight and invulnerability, by a
wizard. In the comics, Shazam and Black Adam are
arch-enemies who got their powers from the same
source, but opted for different paths afterward.
"I kneel before no one."
"Get me out of here!"
With both characters now officially in the
DC Extended Universe, many comic book fans
have been eager to see the two square off
against one another. But it appears that
confrontation isn't happening any time soon.
Johnson has reportedly nixed a planned Black
Adam appearance in the "Shazam!" sequel,
"Shazam! Fury of the Gods." Film reporter
Umberto Gonzalez tweeted,
using Johnson's nickname,
Johnson's decision isn't necessarily a surprise.
He doesn't seem to be big on the character of
Shazam, despite his historical connection to
Black Adam. The 2019 film "Shazam!" was poised
to introduce Black Adam in a scene where the
newly superpowered members of the Shazam family
sat on their thrones before realizing there
was a seventh seat that sat empty. The Wrap
reported that Johnson quashed the scene, as well
as any other reference to Black Adam in the film.
In an August 2022 Vanity Fair interview, Johnson
confirmed that Black Adam originally had a
prominent part in "Shazam!" He noted that
the script originally served as an origin
story for both characters, but he wasn't
open to such an arrangement. He explained,
Johnson said that he made a call to Warner
Bros. executives and insisted they separate
the characters, allowing "Shazam!" to develop
its own tone independent of Black Adam.
"The hierarchy of power in the
DC universe is about to change."
Fandom Wire caught up with Zachary Levi, who plays
Shazam, at Comic Con Portugal in December 2022,
and asked him about whether Black Adam
and Shazam would meet on screen. Levi
responded that he has no idea whether the two
characters would get a chance to interact and
has no influence over how the story would
play out. He did playfully point out,
though, that if he had the opportunity to punch
Dwayne Johnson in the face, he would take it.
The Hollywood Reporter called a
sequel to "Black Adam" "unlikely"
now that James Gunn and Peter Safran
have taken over as the new heads of
DC studios. It's one of a slate of planned
projects the two have reportedly scrapped.
While on stage at Comic Con Portugal, Levi
was asked about his own character's cinematic
future. Levi responded that Gunn and Safran
are friends of his and joked that friendship
would be in jeopardy if they didn't have Shazam
as a part of their plans for DC going forward.
In an interview with Collider, "Shazam!" and
"Shazam! Fury Of The Gods" director David F.
Sandberg was also asked about plans for Black
Adam and Shazam to interact in future films. He
responded that he has not been involved in
any conversations about the two characters
coming face to face, adding that both characters
were on their own trajectories at the moment.